- Okay, so today,
we're talking about the
resurgent right in the West.
Let's get fix our intuitions
with a little walk down memory lane.
- [Ronald Reagan] In Chicago,
they found a woman who holds the record.
She used 80 names, 30
addresses, 15 telephone numbers
to collect food stamps, social security,
veteran's benefits for four non-existent
deceased veterans husbands
as well as welfare.
Her tax free cash income alone
has been running $150,000 a year.
- So that was Ronald Reagan
running for the Republican nomination
against Gerald Ford in 1976,
which he was unsuccessful,
and that's his famous
welfare queens speech
which would become
if things had been able
to go viral in those days,
it did the paper equivalent of going viral
and it represented this frontal assault
on the welfare state,
on what might be more broadly referred to
as the postwar consensus
that had prevailed
in almost all of the capitalist
democracies since the 1950s.
In the US, it went by the
name of the Great Society
ushered in by Lyndon Johnson
which was not only the
civil rights legislation,
but the creation of Medicare,
considerable expansion of many components
of the welfare state.
In Britain, it was of course
the postwar government
of Clement Attlee voted
into office in 1945
that put into place the major elements
of the British welfare state.
And in many of the
European social democracies
as they came to be called,
we got countries that were
marked by strong welfare
and other forms of social protections
such as health insurance,
unemployment insurance, pensions,
progressive tax systems,
a lot of redistribution
through the tax system,
much more steeply progressive tax systems
than in any of those countries today.
And it's important to say
that the support for
this postwar consensus
was substantially bipartisan.
So for example, in Britain
when the Conservatives under Churchill
came back into power in 1951,
many people said, "Oh,
they're gonna roll back
"everything that labor has done."
Not a bit of it actually.
They even expanded it.
And through much of the
1950s, '60s, and '70s,
you saw in most countries
the recognition of a kind of
what seemed to be a
substantially bipartisan support
for this welfare state.
In the US, in the Nixon Administration,
of course, there was some
pressure for lower taxes,
but still, much of the
welfare state was preserved
and in some ways it was even expanded.
They got things like,
which I'll be talking
about later in the course,
such as universal basic income.
Nixon has supported what he
called a negative income tax,
a kind of refundable tax credit.
We've ended up getting something
that's a cousin of that.
In Europe in countries like Germany
where they have coalition governments,
in the '60s and '70s,
they were basically dominated
by the social democrats.
First, Willy Brandt,
and then Helmut Schmidt.
After in the early '80s,
for reasons we'll be
talking about next time,
the social democrats got weaker
and Helmut Kohl's Conservatives took over.
But it was still,
there was very substantial support
for European social democracy
across the political spectrum.
For example, in the '60s
and '70s in France and Italy
where Communist parties
had been very strong
and had traditionally been
more Stalinist like Communist parties,
we had the advent of Euro-Communism.
What was Euro-Communism?
Well, one feature of it
was that it was denounced
by the Soviet Union
as revisionist deviationism.
And the other was that the standing joke
in Italy in the 1970s
was how can you tell that
which is the Communist
politician in parliament?
How do you tell the Communist
from the other politicians?
And the answer was because
they have more expensive suits.
So the Euro-Communists
again stop pushing this idea
that social democracy was a way station
on the way to Soviet style Communism
and instead was a particular form
of political and social
organization that had come to stay.
And it was seen to be as I said,
a very broad bipartisan,
or in Europe, multipartisan consensus.
And this is what starts
to come under attack
in the late 1970s and early 1980s
that Reagan is taking dead aim
at the heart of that consensus
and the new attack is marked
by hostility to trade unions
and the welfare state.
It's hostility to progressive taxation
and hostility to regulation,
the sort of forerunner
of the neoliberalism
that would be coming later.
And as in Reagan's famous slogan,
government is not the
solution to our problems.
Government is the problem.
We have to weaken the power
of government in the economy
and let the market run.
This is the basic idea.
Now, the first thing to say about this
is when people like Reagan
and Thatcher came into power in the,
Reagan got selected in
1980, in the 1980 election.
Margaret Thatcher comes to power in 1979.
She had beaten Edward Heath
for the Conservative
Party leadership in 1975
in the first competitive
election for a leader
in the Conservative Party in its history
and people were quite stunned by this
and she'd been thought to be a minor,
second tier cabinet official
without much future in the party.
And indeed, I think it was Geoffrey Howe
who said she'll be gone in six months.
Turned out she was leader
of the Conservative Party for 15 years
and Prime Minister for
11 and a half years.
But I think it's fair
to say that most people
did not take Reagan
and Thatcher seriously.
They saw them as real threats,
but most people in the establishment,
the political establishment,
the economic establish,
didn't take them seriously
as long term threats.
Those people tended to see this
as a kind of aberrational outcome
and that things would revert to normal.
Social democracy was
about alternation in power
between center right
and center left parties,
and this was a center right moment,
but things would revert.
There were a few discordant voices.
In the US perhaps, the most prescient one
was a man by the name of Kevin
Philips who wrote a book,
published a book in 1969
called "The Emerging
Conservative Majority"
predicting the rise of the new right
in pretty much the form that it took.
But he wasn't,
he was later on given great credit
for having predicted this,
but for the most part,
for the most part,
people did not see this
as any kind of sea change
or fundamental realignment of politics.
And just to give you a sense in Britain.
In 1980, the principle
intellectual architect
of Thatcher's revolution
was Sir Keith Joseph
and he was her trade and industry minister
and he was the source of
all her economic ideas
about monetarism and cutting spending.
And here is Michael Foot
who is by then the leader of
the Labor Party in opposition
commenting on Keith Joseph
in the House of Commons
just to give you a sense of how seriously
they really took the threat from Thatcher.
- [Michael] I wouldn't like to miss out
the right honorable gentleman,
the Secretary of State for Industry
who's had such a tremendous
effect upon the government
and our politics altogether.
And as I see the right
honorable late gentleman
walking around the
country looking puzzled,
and forlorn, and
wondering what's happened,
(audience laughing)
I've often tried to remember
what he reminds me of
and the other day, I hit upon it
because I recall that in my youth
when I used to go in Plymouth,
yes, I know, quite a time ago.
(audience laughing)
You'll come to that one in a moment too.
But I used to go when I lived in Plymouth
every Saturday night
along to the Palace Theater
and the favorite I always
used to watch there
was a magician conjurer
and they used to have in the audience
dressed up as one of the most prominent
alderman in the place
a person who was sitting at
the back of the audience.
And the magician conjurer
would come forward
and say that he wanted
to have from the audience
a beautiful watch.
And he would go amongst the audience.
He'd go up to the alderman
and eventually take off
him a marvelous gold watch.
And he'd bring it right
back onto the stage.
He'd enfold it in a
beautiful red handkerchief.
He placed it on the table
there in front of us.
He took up his mallet and he hit it!
Smashed to smithereens!
And then on his countenance would come
exactly the puzzled look
of the right honorable--
(audience laughing)
And he would step forward,
and he would step forward.
He would step forward right 'til he,
he'd step forward right
to the front of the stage
and he'd say, "I'm very sorry.
"I'm very sorry.
"I've forgotten the rest of the trick."
(audience laughing)
That's the situation of the government.
They've forgotten the rest of the trick.
It doesn't work
and unless any objector might come along
and suggest that it was only a trick,
I can assure that at the
Palace Theater in Plymouth,
the way it was played,
he used to come along at
the end of the very act
and say, "I'm very sorry.
"I've still forgotten the trick."
That's the situation in this country.
- So there was Michael Foot
making fun of Keith Joseph
as a kind of buffoon who
didn't know what he was doing
and getting lots of positive
reinforcement for that,
but of course, the joke
really was on Michael Foot.
Three years later,
he ran unsuccessfully
against Margaret Thatcher
and his election manifesto was called
the longest suicide note in history
subsequently by historians.
So the joke was really on Foot
and he completely
underestimated the staying power
of what was coming down the pike.
So that's our agenda today
and we're gonna look at the
sources and implications
of the resurgence of right wing politics
across the Western democracies.
So we're gonna look at
several sources of this,
one being the collapse of Communism,
the second being
embedded in the logic of
distributive politics,
and the third being
the changing power
relations in the economy.
And all three of these
things have an influence
or should have an influence
on how we think about the
resurgence of the right
and its political implications.
And when we think about
its political implications,
I'm gonna talk briefly
today but more next time
about those implications
in two-party systems
like Britain and the US
versus in multiparty systems
where like we have on
much of the continent.
So, let's start with the effects
of the collapse of Communism.
When the wall came down
and when the Soviet Union
started disintegrating,
many, many intellectuals
and analytical commentators
thought that this would be good
for European parties on the left.
They thought generally
that it would be good for two reasons.
One, it made it clear that
European social democracy
or what we think of as a great society
kind of political economy in the US
is not a way station on the future
to some either more statused,
if you like, outcome.
That once we'd think of it
rather as a kind of permanent equilibrium
that can be defended on its own terms
and is not something that's
gonna produce something worse.
Another way of putting
perhaps the same point
is it gets rid of the kind of bogeyman
to mobilize against from the right.
So you know that if you propose
slight increases in progressive taxation
or you improve healthcare,
the notion of that you're trying to do
is create Communism becomes less credible
if there's no Communism in
the world left to create.
And many people thought that
with the Communist threat gone,
the end of the Cold War,
we wouldn't need to mobilize
against the Soviet Union anymore,
that all of the money that had
been spent on the arms race
could be plowed back into
the Western economies
and we were in for a
continuation, if you like,
of the benign social democracy
and maybe the power would shift
once more back to the left.
Maybe the right wing governments
in say in Britain and the US,
or the fact that power in
Germany had now shifted
as I already said from the
social democrats to the CDU,
maybe it would shift back.
And what all of that failed
to take account of was that,
and this is really the story
of Tony Judt's book "Postwar,"
some of which I've put on the syllabus,
is that the social democratic
economies and welfare states
depended on a very fortuitous arrangement
of demographic, economic,
and geopolitical
circumstances after the war.
The demographic one was
that you had big working age populations
relative to what we call
dependent populations.
We think of the dependency ratio
is the ratio of working age to dependent.
And dependent is defined
under the age of 15
and above the age of 65.
And of course, what really matters
from the point of view
of the fiscal health
of the welfare state is the older crowd
because parents mostly
internalize the cost of children
whereas governments in turn
have to bear the cost of elderly people.
And for the most part in
all of these countries,
we had big working populations
and relatively small elderly populations.
That would change as the baby boomer bulge
worked its way through the population.
And so there's one big
source of fiscal stress
inexorably coming at all of these systems
as the ratio of working people
to retired people would increase.
Then secondly, much of the economic health
of these countries had been result
of the enormous infusion
of funds by the Americans,
the Marshall Plan in Europe,
the rebuilding of the Japanese economy,
and the fact that as I
mentioned to you earlier,
Europe was not spending
money on its own defense
so it had the resources to
build up its domestic economies.
And that too would go away
or would start to diminish
as the Cold War ended.
Also, the American interest
in sustaining these economies
as bulwarks against the Soviet system
would start to diminish
as the Cold War ended.
So the idea that European social democracy
was sort of a permanent equilibrium
was by no means obvious.
It's certainly not in retrospect.
A second thing to notice
is that while the bogeymen of Communism
might not have been there
around which the Conservative,
the ideological right could organize,
there are always other potential bogeymen
and particularly as it's
turned out since 9/11,
Islamic fundamentalism is
an alternative bogeyman
around which to organize
political movements
and it has the added advantage
that it's not a threat
to Democratic capitalism.
You know, when Islamist regimes,
when Islamists do come to power
whether it's in Iran
or Libya under Gaddafi,
they run capitalist systems badly.
There's no alternative.
There's no Islamist model of the economy.
So the idea that one
has to worry about them
as a threat to capitalism
in a way that Communism
had once been perceived
is no longer there.
And that's important because
it diminishes the incentive
to buy off working class discontent.
So if you think about,
go back to the new deal,
after the Depression,
Communist Party in the
US was quite powerful.
It's very influential in American unions,
particularly in the CIO.
We had 20% unemployment.
There was real fear in the
aftermath of the Depression
that Communism might
claim hearts and minds
of large numbers of American workers
and that is partly what
motivated business elites
and others to at least
tacitly support the new deal.
The notion was that you want to make sure
America's workers do not
reach a state of affairs
where they think they have
nothing to lose but their chains.
And so my colleague Peter Swenson
has done tremendous scholarship on this,
but actually what Swenson shows is that
there's never been significant
expansion of a welfare state,
even the European welfare
states by the way,
without significant at least tacit
and sometimes active
support from business.
And part of it in the '30s and '40s
was Keynesian thinking
about revising the economy
or proto-Keynesian thinking.
The general theory didn't come out
until well after the Depression,
but there were many people
making those kinds of
arguments at the time.
But it was also political.
It was this idea
that you want to give
the dispossessed people
who had been most harmed by the Depression
a stake in the existing order.
And similar arguments were
made in Britain and Europe.
For instance, Ralph Miliband,
the father of Ed and David Miliband
was a political economist
who published a book
in the early '60s I believe it was
called "The Capitalist Industrial State"
in which he argued
the welfare state is
capitalism's best friend.
He was a Marxist,
well to the left even of Ed Miliband,
and he thought that this was a bad thing
because it was preventing the workers
from becoming revolutionary
because they had this stake
in the existing order.
And so this was the notion
that if you don't do this,
there's an alternative model out there
vying for hearts and minds
and we'd better look out for that.
Once the alternative model has gone away,
once there's no longer a Soviet Union,
it's much easier to discount all of that.
It's much easier to say
well, let's, you know,
you might not say it,
but think move to the suburbs
and build more prisons.
It's not obvious
that there's any reason
of the sort that existed
when there was a Communist
alternative out there
to continue to maintain
expensive welfare states
that would require
substantial levels of taxation
and maybe increasing levels of taxation
given the changes in the demography.
So the short of it is that
those who had faith in the idea
that the end of the Cold War
was gonna be good for left
of center parties were wrong
and things have played out
quite differently since that time.
So that's our first thing.
But I want now to turn to
some more analytical thinking.
Let's put on my analytical hat here.
Some more analytical thinking
about the logic of distributive politics
because I think people
don't think clearly enough
about just what that logic is
when they think about what's gonna happen
in different political scenarios.
So this is a famous picture of a hat
from the beginning of "The Little Prince,"
Antoine de Saint-Exupery.
And as you might recall,
it's the very beginning of the book.
He decides he wants to frighten the adults
and he's gonna frighten the adults
by drawing a picture
of a boa constrictor eating an elephant.
So he does.
And he's absolutely devastated
when the adults say, "That's
a nice hat you've drawn."
And he's furious.
So he has to draw another
picture showing the elephant,
a sort of X-ray.
But he's so despondent
that he decides to abandon
his career as an artist
and instead become a
pilot which he duly does.
Now, one thing we can
know about this story
is that the adults he
was trying to frighten
were not economists
because had they been economists,
he might have been able to frighten them
with this picture because
instead of not seeing,
instead of seeing it as a hat,
they might have seen it
as a picture of the income distribution.
And in particular, this feature
of the income distribution
which is that the median income
is always below the mean income.
Why would that be?
Why is the median income
always below the mean?
Yup.
- [Male Speaker] (mumbles) there are
some extremely rich people.
- Very rich people, right?
The very rich people out here.
In fact, you know,
Gates, and Soros, and these,
they're probably on the other side
of (mumbles) Street down
there actually, right?
And so that pulls up the average, right?
So that means that in every,
you know,
obviously there's a cut off point here
because there's some level below
which people won't survive,
but the very rich people
pull up the average
so there are always more people
below the average income.
And so this had for a long
time led political economists
to think that politicians who
are trying to win election
will be responsive the median voter
and there'd sorta be a kind of impetus
to redistribute downwardly
because politicians need votes,
they need to get elected,
and so they will do that.
This median voter is gonna
be below the mean income.
And indeed, this is a very old argument.
So for example in the 19th century,
people like John Stuart Mill were afraid
of expanding the franchise
for exactly this reason.
And they came up with things
like giving two votes
to university graduates
as a way to sort of blunt it.
And Karl Marx after he'd
been disappointed in 1830
when Communism had not arrived
and he'd been disappointed in 1848
when the revolutions
had not become Communist
and he'd been disappointed
in the Paris commune in 1871,
he and Engel started talking about
the parliamentary road to Socialism.
And this was exactly the same idea
that maybe the workers would
do through the ballot box,
what they had not done at the barricades.
And the 20th century's ideas
the median voter theorem
which basically says
that politicians in
search of the median voter
are gonna support downward redistribution.
A very famous paper by two
people called Meltzer and Richard
which I think is somewhere
in the recommended
readings on the syllabus.
If not, it should be.
And so the biggest puzzle of
20th century political economy
is that this does not in fact happen.
That there's lots of redistribution
in Democratic capitalist systems,
but it's all kinds of distribution.
It can be from urban to
rural sectors of the economy.
It can be from one industry to another.
It can be done through food subsidies.
It can be done in all kinds of ways,
but there's sometimes,
there's regressive redistribution
in capitalist systems.
We'll talk later about the
repeal of the estate tax
which is an example of
using the political system
to actually redistribute in ways
that produce more inequality.
And so that being the case
that the sort of standard expectations,
the folk expectations that
once you've got majority rule
with the universal franchise,
the poor are gonna soak the rich.
Why wouldn't they?
They've got less.
They're gonna soak the
rich, but it doesn't happen.
And so people have tried to understand
why that doesn't happen
and there are basically two approaches
to thinking about that.
So, one would be to say well,
I've got one dimension here.
The left wing party wants redistribution.
The right wing party
doesn't want redistribution
and the median voter's
gonna want redistribution
and so the right wing party
is gonna sorta be dragged to the left
in search of the median voter
or it's gonna lose, right?
But what if there's
another dimension as well?
What if there's a dimension like race?
So what if there's a
dimension where people
have racially exclusionary attitudes
versus inclusionary attitudes?
And then it might be the case that well,
then it depends how much
they compare about race
versus how much they care
about income or wealth, okay?
And so this is the story
of Richard Nixon's
southern strategy, right?
So what happens.
1964, you get the Civil Rights Act.
1965, we get the Voting Rights Act.
Lyndon Johnson is famously
reputed to have said,
"Democrats have lost the
South for a generation.
"I've lost the South for the
Democrats for a generation."
Historians now debate
whether he actually said it,
but it was widely attributed to him.
And the notion was that
the Democrats historically
had been the dominant party in the South
and now that they had become associated
with the Civil Rights Act,
the Voting Rights Act,
there was gonna be backlash
and Nixon and his advisors
thought he could
capitalize on that backlash
by offering to essentially
limit the effects
of the Voting Rights and
Civil Rights Act in the South,
stop that,
and that would make,
this would be the way
in which the Republicans
could attract voters
who had previously supported the Democrats
for economic reasons.
And so once you put a
second dimension into play,
if you like,
it's no longer the case
that the median voter
will necessarily want
downward redistribution
because they may want preservation
of their racial status quo more.
And so this is one of the
ways in which scholars.
My colleague in the
Political Science Department,
John Roemer has developed
a number of these models
that show this.
Once you put a second
dimension whether it,
I'm just putting race here.
It could be xenophobia.
It could be women's rights.
There might be another dimension.
Again, you think about women's rights.
Women may think the
pro-choice pro-life dimension
more important than the economic dimension
and so vote differently.
So once you put other
dimensions into play,
maybe the median voter won't
vote for redistribution.
So that's one possible story
about why we have not seen
the sorts of developments
that one might anticipate.
Here's another story.
So this is what game theorists refer to
as the majority rule divide a dollar game.
And here, the intuition is
that if you divide a
dollar by majority rule,
no matter how you divide it,
there is some potential
majority to upset that division.
So if you think if they start
out with an equal division,
you can see here that Stannis and Arya
can decide to completely
dispossess Joffrey
and keep it all to themselves.
But of course, if we think of
things going around over time,
then what if Joffrey's gonna come along
to Arya and say, "I'll
offer you a different deal.
"You can keep 2/3 of it or 60% of it
"and I'll take 40% of it, all right?"
And if that were the case,
if that became the new status quo,
Stannis would come up and
propose something else.
And this could go on, and on, and on.
And what the finding is
is that it never ends.
So that if you have majority rule
dividing up any divisible good over time,
there is no distribution
that in principle is not susceptible
to being upset by some new majority.
So notice a couple of things
about the majority rule
divide a dollar game
that are very important
for us going forward.
The first is you don't need
a second dimension here
to get instability, right?
Maybe there's a second
dimension, maybe there isn't,
but it's not necessary
to have a second dimension
to get instability.
You can get instability
with one dimension, right?
Just money.
This whole game is just about money.
And that carries a further implication
which is that interests alone
will not produce effective demand
for dominant redistribution
or for retaining any
particular distribution.
Now, we're gonna be bringing into play
the framework of interests,
ideals, and institutions
that I mentioned to you last week.
And notice here
I'm not just talking about
interests as selfish.
For example, the three people
playing the divided dollar game.
Maybe one wants to give the
money to save the whales.
One wants to give the
money to soup kitchens
and one wants to spend
it protecting wolves
as my friend Nicoly up there
would probably want to do.
So they try to maximize
their share of the pie,
but we're not saying they're
selfish people, right?
But all we're saying is that
if they want to maximize
their share of the pie,
the interest in maximizing
is not gonna be enough
to sustain any particular distribution
because if it's just that,
there will always be
someone who will come along
and offer you a better deal, right?
So interests alone are
not gonna be sufficient
to get people to support
any particular distribution
including, of course,
distribution from the
average to the median voter.
So if interests alone are not enough,
let's think about the other two concepts.
Let's think about ideals.
So what we're really saying is
in order for the median voter
to achieve downward redistribution,
all these people have to vote together.
All of these people to
the left of this line
have to vote together, right?
Because if the wealthy
can buy off the poor
with bread and circuses
and make the middle class pay for it,
you can get a coalition
of the rich and the poor
against the middle class
or you can (mumbles) 2017 tax cuts.
You give a small cut to
the people at the bottom,
a huge cut to the people at the top.
People in the middle
internalize the cost of that.
Again, it's a majority rule,
it's a majority coalition.
It's not gonna be downward redistributive.
So all of these people
would have to vote together.
So they'd have to some ideals
we can think about first
to get them to vote together.
So what ideals might there be?
So one ideal obviously is
what people think is fair.
People think, you know,
what is a fair distribution?
Maybe you can motivate them with that.
So here's the next question
is well, what is fairness?
Well, here's one answer to that.
- So a final experiment that
I want to mention to you
is our fairness study.
So what we did is we put two
Capuchin monkeys side by side.
Again, these animals,
they live in a group.
They know each other.
We take them out of the group,
put them in a test chamber.
And there's a very simple
task that they need to do
and if you give both of
them cucumber for the task,
the two monkeys side by side,
they're perfectly willing to
do this 25 times in a row.
So cucumber even though
it's really only water in my opinion,
but cucumber is perfectly fine for them.
Now, if you give the partner grapes.
The food preferences
of my Capuchin monkeys
correspond exactly with the
prices in the supermarket.
And so if you give them
grapes as a far better food,
then you create inequity between them.
So that's the experiment we did.
Recently, we videotaped it
with new monkeys who
had never done the task
thinking that maybe they
would have a stronger reaction
and that turned out to be right.
The one on the left is the
monkey who gets cucumber.
The one on the right is
the one who gets grapes.
The one who gets cucumber,
note that the first piece of
cucumber is perfectly fine,
the first piece she eats.
Then she sees the other one getting grape
and you will see what happens.
So she gives a rock to us.
That's the task
and we give her a piece of
cucumber and she eats it.
The other one needs to give a rock to us
and that's what she does.
And she gets a grape and she eats it.
The other one sees that.
She gives a rock to us
now, gets again cucumber.
(audience laughing)
She tests the rock now against the wall.
She needs to give it to us
and she gets cucumber again.
(audience laughing)
So this is basically
the Wall Street protest
that you see here.
(audience laughing)
- So what he finds there
with the Capuchins is a very,
he's studied it in many,
many, many social animals
and there's plenty of psychology
to support the idea that
human beings are the same.
However, he fundamentally
misinterprets the result of his study.
Anyone think why do we say he
misinterprets the implication,
he doesn't see what this implies?
Yeah.
No?
It's not the Wall Street protestor
because what infuriates this monkey
is that another monkey just
like it is getting more.
The monkey's not bothered
that the researcher has a bowl
full of cucumbers and grapes, right?
This is a very robust finding
in the social psychology
literature about people.
Their sense of the word welfare
is often other regarding,
but they make relatively
local comparisons.
They do not compare themselves to people
very different from themselves
in the socioeconomic distribution.
So where steel workers
might compare themselves to auto workers
or coal miners might compare themselves
to people working in oil fields.
And this is true, by the way,
up and down the occupational scale.
So a professor will be
much angrier to discover
that he or she earns $5,000 less
than the professor in the next office
than to discover that he
or she earns $500,000 less
than the attorney who lives next door.
People tend to make
relatively local comparisons
and later on when we come
to populism and all that,
we'll discuss the implications of that
in the politics that
we're seeing right now.
And so the point to make here
is that people don't
make global comparisons.
They tend to compare people
to people like themselves.
Now, you could say.
Yeah?
- Is it only by occupation?
- No, not necessarily.
I mean, there's studies
of children for example.
You give a little boy a
half a glass of orange juice
and then you give his sister a full glass
and he was happy before.
Now, he's furious, right?
So it depends what your
reference group is.
Paul Bloom who gave the Devane Lectures
about four or five years ago
is the local expert on reference groups,
but it doesn't have to
be in the same industry.
It's got to be the kind of people
you consider yourself to be like
and by whom you want to
be given esteem, right?
So now, you might say,
well, that's not necessarily
fatal for solidarity
because if you say well,
I want to have at least
as much as people like me.
You could say well, let's get together
and make sure we all get it, right?
So it's not obviously fatal to solidarity.
And that's basically what Marx's theory
of consciousness raising was about.
But the trouble is
that it competes with
other ideals of fairness.
So let's just consider a couple
that are relevant to where we're headed.
- Next Tuesday is election day.
Next Tuesday, all of
you will go to the polls
and stand there in the polling place
and make a decision.
I think when you make that decision,
it might be well if you would ask yourself
are you better off than
you were four years ago?
Is it easier for you to go
and buy things in the stores
than it was four years ago?
Is there more or less
unemployment in the country
than there was four years ago?
And if you answer all
of those questions yes,
why then I think your
choice is very obvious
as to who you will vote for.
- So there, he's saying
something quite different.
He's saying ask yourself.
This is Ronald Reagan in
1984 running for re-election.
He's saying four years ago
when I came into office,
some here can remember
what it was like in 1980.
Interest rates were at 19%.
Inflation was 12 or 13%.
The economy was in pretty bad shape
and by 1984, things were better.
So he's saying you look
at your circumstances now
compared to four years ago
and are you better off or not?
This is what we might call a
self referential comparison.
It has nothing to do
with what other people are getting, right?
And it's not important
from your point of view
Reagan is anticipating what
other people are getting.
And this is what economists call
a Pareto improvement, right?
Economists are all about absolute gains,
not about relative gains.
People want to get on as high
an indifference curve as they can
in standard economic models
without reference to
the indifference curves
that others might be on.
Just to take the same
logic across the channel,
here's another formulation of it.
- There is no doubt that the
Prime Minister has in many ways
achieved substantial
success for the economy.
(people exclaiming)
There is one statistic
that I understand is not
however challengeable
and that is that over her 11 years,
the gap between the richest 10%
and the poorest 10% in this country
has widened substantially.
- [Male Speaker] That's right.
- How can she say
at the end of her chapter
of British politics
that she can justify
many people in the
constituency such as mine
being relatively much poorer off,
much less well housed,
and much less well provided
than it was in 1979?
Surely, she accepts that is not a record
that she or any Prime
Minister can be proud of.
- Mr. Speaker, all levels
of income are better off
than they were in 1979,
but what the honorable member is saying
is that he would rather
the poor were poorer
provided the rich were less rich.
Once they start to talk about the gap,
they'd rather the gap were that,
down here, that.
Not that,
but that.
- [Male Speaker] That's it.
- So long as the gap is smaller,
so long as the gap
is smaller--
- Order!
- They'd rather have the poor poorer.
- So you know, there it is.
Two fundamentally antithetical
conceptions of fairness.
So how should we think about
the contest between them?
Which is more powerful
politically, do you think?
Or maybe that's the wrong way to put it.
What are the conditions under which
one might become more
powerful than the other?
Any reflections on this?
Yeah.
We're gonna give you the microphone, yeah.
Do you want to give it to him?
Yeah.
- [Male Speaker] Can everyone hear me?
Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Male Speaker] It
brings back to the mean
and average income we saw previously.
If you have more people that have less,
then politically you're
gonna have more people
who are going to vote for the income.
- So just run with that a little bit.
So if you were designing a party platform
trying to appeal to more
solidarity based idea
of getting more people
to resist the Reagan
and Thatcher logic here,
what would your argument be?
- [Male Speaker] To resist
Thatcher and Reagan?
My main argument would
be we're all born equal.
We need to earn the same thing.
There's no reason why
other people gain more.
- Okay and now, if you had to,
if you had to bet in an upcoming election
that you were right,
how much of your own money would you bet?
- [Male Speaker] This is taking
the country to my opinions,
but I think there's a good
chance it will be successful
in the next 15 months unfortunately.
- Okay.
You think the people's basic conception
of a solidarity based
conception of fairness
can actually command people's support
despite the appeals to what we might call
an economist conception
of absolute improvements?
Any other arguments
that somebody could imagine making
in support of that notion?
Yes, sir.
You need the microphone, yeah.
- [Male Speaker] Since
the Reagan administration,
there has been no real growth
in wages of the middle class.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Male Speaker] And all
the additional productivity
has gone to the upper class.
So I think that is something
that you could use as a political
argument that would work.
- So how would you make the argument?
- That life is not better than it was
50 years ago for most of the people.
That if anything, your
salary is the same and your,
and the likelihood of you
keeping your salary is less.
You're less secure
and you're at the same level
that you were 30 years ago.
- Okay, so I see you oscillating now
between two logics here.
One is you're saying the
world's become more unequal
and the other is that you're saying
people are becoming more insecure, right?
So those two things are not the same
and they gotta be importantly different.
And what I'm gonna be
arguing later in the course
is that when people become insecure,
there's a very different politics.
Insecurity is not the
same thing as inequality.
People can be afraid of insecurity
even if they're relatively well
off if they feel threatened.
Fear of insecurity produces
a very different politics
than outrage at inequality.
And what's going on here
is that if you look at the
Reagan and Thatcher arguments,
in addition to being
completely self referential.
They're just saying,
they're both saying why
should the poor care
what the rich have
if the poor are better
off than they were before
or at least as good as?
So they're basically
appealing to two things.
One is absolute improvement's
more important than relative changes.
And the other is that people, again,
they then are appealing for
prospects for upward mobility.
They're saying you, you know,
Reagan famously said I want an America
where anybody can become
a millionaire, right?
People should be able to get ahead.
Now, and that was certainly a difference
between the politics of
the new right in the 1980s
and the politics of conservatism
pro-market arguments today
which revolve more
around what psychologists
and economists call loss aversion.
It's no longer a politics about
promising upward mobility.
It's actually a politics revolving around
as you said wages have stagnated
and perhaps in real
terms, actually gone down.
People are more insecure.
Make America great again
is a slogan which implies
that something's been taken away from you
and I'm gonna bring it back, right?
It's a very different notion than
America's best days lie ahead.
Now, it's interesting that Reagan
was responsible for both those slogans.
Make America great again
and America's best days lie ahead.
And in 2016, Trump used the first
and Hillary used the second.
But of course, the context in which
Hillary was talking about
America's best days lie ahead
had been an era when we had
had 304 decades of wage stagnation
and growing economic insecurity.
So it was a very different era
than when Reagan and Thatcher
were running in the 1980s.
But those are more contextual things.
I want to just make some more basic points
about the logic of distribution here
which is what Thatcher's
success was keying off of
was this wonderful line
from the Times obituary
of Benjamin Disraeli.
He died in 1891.
I don't know why
it took them two years
to write the obituary,
but they said,
"He discerned the conservative
nature of the working man
"in the same way as a sculptor
"discerns an angel in a block of marble."
So what Disraeli,
he basically understood this logic
of what we might call divide a guinea
rather than divide a dollar,
but that there was plenty
of reasons to think
that you could appeal
to working class voters
to support conservative policies.
And one of the, I think,
enduring myths on the intellectual left
is that when poor people
don't support redistributive politics,
they're somehow acting
against their own interest.
Sort of what's the matter
with Kansas, right?
Thomas Frank.
Why are these people voting
in ways that are not in their interest?
Even setting aside
whether there's a second
dimension like race
which might be part of the story
but it might not be part of the story,
being promised minor
incremental improvements
might be sufficient
to get people to support
a political program
without reference to
what others are doing.
And I think the other thing to say.
You could say okay,
these are two competing
conceptions of fairness.
It's not obvious why one will
win rather than the other,
but the difficulty is
that it's much harder
to hold a solidaristic coalition together
precisely because all you have to do
is start picking off some
people from that coalition
until you've got enough.
So even if 40, or 50, or
60% remain in solidarity
with this basic conception of fairness,
if you could promise
upward mobility to others,
that might be enough.
Or if you could promise
at least repairing the
losses that they've had,
maybe subsidies for the
industries in which they work,
that might be enough.
And again, we'll talk much more
about populism since 2016 later,
but notice that Donald Trump in no rally,
in no campaign speech,
in no piece of campaign literature
ever said he was gonna reduce
the inequality in America.
He said, "I'm gonna bring
industrial jobs back."
He said, "These people are corrupt
"and they've been screwing things up,"
but he did not promise
to reduce inequality.
He promised to give people
absolute improvements
or at least prevent them from experiencing
further absolute losses period.
So it makes it harder, we might say,
all else equal, it's harder to sustain
solidaristic conceptions of fairness
because that's a coalition
that can be picked apart in different ways
and all it takes is getting enough people
to support what you want to do
and it starts to disintegrate.
And that's what Thatcher did basically.
She appealed to lower
middle class workers,
shop keepers, and working class voters
with upwardly mobile aspirations
and comparable things happened
elsewhere in the 1980s.
So the upshot is
that even without a second
dimension like race,
solidarity is always
vulnerable to splintering
by these ideology,
by these other ideologies
or people promising to pick off somebody
by promising them absolute gains
or something better as part
of some different coalition.
So it sounds like ideals
of fairness are not enough.
They might help build a coalition
and they might motivate
people some of the time,
but they're probably not gonna be enough.
So what about institutions?
What institutions could there be
that would sustain a solidaristic,
what I'm calling here a
solidaristic conception
that would get people to support
single political platforms
that might at least
prevent regressive change
or promote progressive change?
Unions, yeah.
They seem like the obvious
candidate 'cause unions,
unions are basically organizations
that will pull together the people
to the left of the median voter.
So let's take a look at
what we think about unions.
- [Male Speaker] Sam Donaldson, ABC News--
- [Male Speaker] A strike
by air traffic controllers.
From the President, a strong warning.
They are in violation of the law
and if they do not report
for work within 48 hours,
they have forfeited their
jobs and will be terminated.
- [Male Speaker] From the
union, a defiant response.
- The controllers out there
firmly believe in what they are doing
and we will continue the strike.
(orchestral music)
- [Male Speaker] From ABC,
this is World News Tonight
with Peter Jennings at the
foreign desk in London.
And from our desk in
Washington, Frank Reynolds.
- Good evening.
The strike began as scheduled
at seven o'clock local time this morning.
Its impact was immediate.
Most flights delayed, many more canceled,
but there was no delay
in the reaction of the federal government
led by the president himself.
We have a series of reports tonight.
First, here is White House
correspondent Sam Donaldson.
- [Sam] Four hours after the strike began,
President Reagan described
the aides as very angry
and very determined
to serve notice on the
air traffic controllers
that they had better return
to work quickly or else.
- Government cannot close
down the assembly line.
It has to provide without interruption
the protective services
which are government's reason for being.
It was in recognition of this
that the Congress passed a law
forbidding strikes by government employees
against the public safety.
It is for this reason
that I must tell those
who fail to report for duty this morning,
they are in violation of the law
and if they do not report
for work within 48 hours,
they have forfeited their
jobs and will be terminated.
- [Sam] Strong as the
threat of firing may be,
the administration moved rapidly
to employ other weapons as well.
Court proceedings to force
the strikers back to work
were begun in 19 separate courts.
Criminal charges were being
prepared against individuals.
The first cases would be
brought against union leaders,
but FBI agents are compiling
a complete list of strikers.
The union's three and a half
million dollar strike fund
has been impounded by court order
and a petition has been filed
asking for decertification of the union
meaning to put it out
of business permanently.
The President was asked why
such strong action immediately?
Why not some lesser action to begin with?
- What lesser action can there be?
The law is very explicit.
They are violating the law.
- The President is said by
an aide to be tough as nails
in his determination to break this strike.
And this morning, Mr. Reagan
reminisced in the Oval Office
about Calvin Coolidge's
similar determination
and success in breaking the
Boston Police strike of 1919
when Coolidge was
governor of Massachusetts.
In this case, Mr. Reagan wanted to make
the deadline for firing 24 hours at first.
He finally settled on 48
in order to make certain
that no air traffic
controller could say later,
he didn't get the word.
The President seems convinced
that by being tough,
he can force many of the
union members back to work.
He also seems convinced
that being tough is what the public wants.
Sam Donaldson, ABC News, the White House.
- And he did indeed fire
those air traffic controllers.
Let's go forward three years in the UK.
- Mr. Chairman, what we have
seen in the past few weeks
is not picketing at all.
It is an attempt by
force to prevent others
from doing what they have a right to do.
(audience applauding)
It is intimidation.
It is unlawful assembly.
Our duty demands and the
national interest requires
that we see that violence does not pay
and is seen not to pay.
(audience applauding)
Let violence cease.
Let the law be kept.
That is the spoken and unspoken hope
and wish of millions
of our fellow citizens.
- So those two confrontations
were emblematic
of the gloves coming off with
the rise of the new right
when Ronald Reagan fired the
air traffic controllers in 1981
and Margaret Thatcher took on the miners
who had been striking through
much of the 1970s in Britain
and broke the miner's union.
And this signaled a start
of a very different attitude
toward unions on the part
of right of center parties.
And many people sort of
date the big change here
to those governments
and those particular sort
of symbolic confrontations.
But the truth is that that
was the tip of an iceberg
that has a much longer provenance.
So if you look at union
membership in the US,
you can see this starts
from, goes from 1973 to 2009,
and it basically falls in half.
And if you take out public sector workers,
it's overall union membership
falls even more dramatically.
You can see here
that private sector unions
have all but disappeared.
But what do these numbers ignore?
What do these graphs not tell us?
Most people know that.
Most people know that since the 1970s,
unionist rates,
unions have gotten a lot smaller.
Yeah?
- [Male Speaker] There are
a lot of jobs going away.
- Yup, that's true,
but what else,
what do these numbers not tell us?
What they don't tell us is
it's not since the 1970s.
It's since the 1950s
that the high watermark
of union membership
in the US economy
is really in the late
1940s and early 1950s.
The Wagner Act protecting unions
had been passed in 1935
as part of FDR's new deal legislation
and had had very tepid opposition
from business initially
partly because of the fears of Communism,
but that rapidly changed
once it became obvious that the US economy
was not gonna disappear,
was not gonna collapse.
And through much of the 1940s,
there was a lot of lobbying
to either get rid of
Wagner or cut it back.
And in 1947, Republican Congress
passed the Taft-Hartley Act
which over President
Truman's veto by the way,
so it was a very powerful
Republican Congress did that,
takes 2/3 in both houses,
and Taft-Hartley cut back on
a lot of union protections.
So part of it was the politics,
but we've seen as America has transformed
from a manufacturing
to a services economy,
it's become less and less unionized
partly for those sorts
of political reasons
and part because it's much harder
to organize service sector
than it is manufacturing,
and mining, and things like that,
and partly because more recently,
the advent of free trade.
The fact that capital is
back to the Hirschman point,
capital has many fewer
exit costs than labor.
Capital is more mobile than labor,
so capital can leave at
much lower cost than labor.
Think about what I said
about different exit costs
being important when we
talked about Hirschman.
And those exit costs for capital
have come down, and down, and down,
and so we saw last time
if they can't make enough money in China,
they just move to Vietnam.
And then they'll go to
Cambodia or some place else.
So you've got low exit cost for capital,
higher exit cost for labor.
And so that makes it very
difficult to sustain unionization.
And this as somebody said
when we were talking about,
this has a lot to do,
the red line there is
a share of the income
going to the top 10%
and the blue line is the
decline in unionization
since the '50s.
And as you can see,
as unions get smaller and smaller,
the inequality is growing.
And somebody else mentioned
as this has happened,
we've seen a declining share of income
going to the middle class.
Again, I'll post these slides
and you can look at them at your leisure.
And this is not only the case in the US.
You won't be able to see these probably,
but these are all countries
in which a different.
You'll be able to see
them when I post them.
They're all countries
in which the proportion of the work force
has declined over the
last several decades.
And they're all the major economies.
Unions have become smaller and weaker.
There are a few exceptions,
places like Belgium, Chile, Mexico.
It's more or less remained flat.
It seems like Finland is about
the only country in the world
in which unionization rates
have actually increased.
And so what are the implications of that?
The implications of that are that unions
which as the gentleman here said
are probably the best
institutional component
for creating solidarity among voters
to vote for certain platforms
are decreasingly well equipped to do that.
And particularly, it has
been conventional wisdom
that in two-party systems,
the unionized workforce
is relatively small
so it's not gonna be able to
get a lot of redistribution.
And so this is a picture
of inequalities in the US,
the UK, Germany, and France
over the past century.
For all countries, it's this U shape.
So we go from the gilded
age to where we are now
more or less in this U shape
with the more equality in
the middle of the century.
But as you can see,
the U is deeper in the US and the UK
which have two party systems
and it's shallower in France and Germany
which have multiparty systems.
And this has been a source
of the conventional wisdom
that two-party systems
are less redistributive
to the median voter
than multi-party systems.
This has been conventional
wisdom for a very long time.
And part of the reason here
is as the left of center party
is less and less connected
to a powerful union movement,
there's gonna be less demand on it
to deliver those kinds of
redistributive changes.
And indeed, there's scholarship
mostly from 20 or 30 years ago
suggesting that multi-party systems
are more responsive to the median voter
in the policies that they actually enact.
Whether that is in fact true anymore
is what we'll talk about next time.
See you on Tuesday.
(calm music)